it is a major major day in American
history today and we will get to it
momentarily quick correction earlier
this week during my analysis of the UK
elections I said Jeremy Corbyn has
resigned as the leader of the Labour
Party he said he will resign but has not
yet resigned I apologise for that
mistake the rest of the analysis remains
as I made it earlier this week today the
House of Representatives is expected to
formally vote to impeach president
Donald Trump it may carry over until
tomorrow
Republicans starting off the hearings
this morning with a number of attempts
to delay various obstructive attempts
including one where they opened up and
said hey we actually just moved to
adjourn let's just cancel it all and go
home of course a move that Democrats who
have the majority in the House voted
down right away depending on how long
debate goes today by the time that you
listen to today's show watch today's
show Donald Trump may already be
impeached or they may not have voted and
maybe that vote will be forthcoming
tomorrow or in the following days
yesterday rallies exploding across the
country in support of Donald Trump's
impeachment now I wasn't sure how much
attendance these rallies would see but
it was truly stunning huge crowds in
major cities and moderately sized cities
and towns all across the United States a
very large turnout in New York City just
one of roughly 600 events people
gathering in Times Square many protests
here in Massachusetts including in
Boston as well as in Cambridge huge
crowds in different parts of Michigan
Nashville Tennessee Washington State I
could not possibly list all of the
places because it was all over the
country in both blue states and red
states I heard from people in Oklahoma
who said that they were at impeachment
rallies people seemingly ready for when
Donald Trump will no longer be a thing
in the news anymore and of course that
will be a long time this is just the
very very beginning so the House of
Representatives may have already voted
will be voting today will be voting soon
six hours of debate scheduled on the
issue we don't know whether this is
going to extend beyond today but we are
going to see only the third ever
impeachment of a president of the United
States of course Andrew Johnson being
impeached but acquitted Bill Clinton
impeached also acquitted and a lot of
folks incorrectly
believe that Richard Nixon was impeached
and remember Richard Nixon resigned
after it became clear because Republican
senators went to him and said listen
you've lost the support of the public
even Republican voters don't support you
if impeachment happens we will have to
convict you and that pushed Richard
Nixon to resign that is a very different
scenario than what we have today in
great part because Richard Nixon didn't
have the benefit of the 24/7
conservative media cycle social media
micro targeting on all of these
different platforms which have made it
so that 62% of Trumpets say I don't care
what Trump does he can't even
hypothetically do anything that would
get me to reconsider my support for him
so let me remind everyone that the Trump
is Right is pretending that what we are
seeing right now is mere partisanship
but remember the nationwide rallies
calling for the impeachment of Barack
Obama I don't remember them because they
didn't happen and Obama did some bad
things for sure remember the nationwide
rallies calling for the impeachment of
George W Bush no as there weren't any
Bush did terrible things and people did
rally correctly against the Iraq war but
this is not normal not every president
generates impeachment again only three
have Donald Trump being the third and
not every president catalyzes nationwide
rallies demanding that they be impeached
Donald Trump tweeting this morning more
than 20 times by the time that the
impeachment debate started in the house
clearly bracing for today including
saying quote can you believe that I will
be impeached today by the radical left
do-nothing Democrats and I did nothing
wrong
exclamation point a terrible thing with
a capital T read the transcripts with
attack capital T of course he has not
released
the transcript from the Ukraine phone
call releasing only a fraction of it
this should never happen to another
president again saying say a prayer
Trump calling for pray religious all of
a sudden now that he is getting
impeached so this is all historic we are
covering it all still the most likely
outcome is that Donald Trump will be
acquitted by the Senate impeachment
trial but I want to take this as an
opportunity because we are seeing
rallies around the country to remind
folks that we need to see crowds and
rallies just as big and bigger
nationally fighting for the climate
fighting to take back control of our
country from the corporate lobbyists
revolving door industrial complex that
we see the financialization of the
economy that we've talked about I've
talked before many times about how what
we really need you know signing
petitions is not going to achieve change
in this country calling our elected
officials alone is not going to achieve
change in this country beyond just
removing Donald Trump I'm talking about
the structural problems that we have
health care climate inequality all of
these things one of the things I've been
talking about for a long time is we need
mass rallies at urban centers and the
problem is that the system that we are
trying to change by its nature makes it
so that people can't afford to go and do
these mass rallies when people can't
miss a day of work because then that
means they don't have the money for rent
they're not going to go to their nearest
urban center and mass rally we need I've
talked about other strategies that is
serious protest strategies strategic
defaults for example and all of these
other things that we've discussed many
times crippling industry to the degree
that it makes our government have to fix
some of the problems we need to see that
kind of activism around more than just
impeaching Donald Trump I hope this will
the 600 rallies yesterday will serve as
a reminder that people can get organized
to that degree but there are going to be
some pains in it because the system is
designed to keep people in an
economically precarious state
such that they can't afford to take a
day off and to go and do this stuff so
that's the way the system works I'm
inspired by the rallies we saw yesterday
we will see the impeachment of Donald
Trump and likely the acquittal but let's
remember that the mass rallies and urban
centers should be utilized as a tool far
beyond simply saying we want Trump to go
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinka it's amazing
it's an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a fifteen minute
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n